william faulkner as people who watch
this channel probably know
is one of my absolute favorite writers
so i figured i would go ahead and give
my review of absalom absalom a book that
i read
fairly recently now let's get into what
everyone says right
so everyone says that absalom absalom is
like
really insanely difficult book that's
very hard to get into
i will say there are parts of it that
are difficult but it's not the
necessarily the comprehension stuff
although it
may be like the trademark of this book
is that there are long ass sentences so
if you
are not into long ass sentences maybe
don't read it
because it has a breathless momentum a
kind of like
nervous anxious terrified momentum
that's just a breathy just
moving and moving and moving and moving
and i may not have
finished this book because the the
content is very
it's a book that is about the south i
will just put it there
it's about quentin thompson essentially
who's a a character in
one of faulkner's other books the sound
of the fury who in the sound of the fury
and this isn't really a spoiler
quentin thompson commits suicide not
even on screen or
in the book of sound and the fury that's
why it's not really a spoiler in absalom
absalom
which was written after the sound of the
fury he is alive
and he is dealing with the story that is
being told to him
by miss coldfield who is telling about
this story about thomas sutpen and the
whole book is about thomas sutpin but we
never actually get to be with thomas
sutpin he's kind of an embodiment of
evil in the way that phlegm snopes is
the embodiment of evil in the
snopes trilogy except thomas sutpen is
almost more horrifying because
he is just an absolute bastard total
psychopath he he basically carves this
stretch of land called the sutpens
hundred out of mississippi
and creates this massive plantation and
creates
a ton of wealth basically quentin
thompson he's a college student you know
he's attending harvard and he's trying
to grapple with the legacies of
basically slavery and that's what this
book is about it's about race it's about
slavery it's about the legacies of
slavery in the south it has been
described in many ways as the anti-gone
with the wind because gone with the wind
came out in the
in the same year 1936 it is shocking
it it truly is like um still like a
shocking
book and horrifying and gross
these are all good things about it there
are like frame narratives within frame
narratives
the book will just take left turns
you'll think that it's just like a brief
little side area
that the book is going and then i'll
just go for 100 pages and it's like okay
everything's just italicized now like
that's just
that's just how it is now you know you
have to just give yourself to the book
and that's what i did and that's
i appreciate that i did do that with
this book because if i hadn't given
myself to this book
i would have been trying to struggle and
try to understand every little word i'm
fortunate i didn't have to read this for
a class because i'm sure if i read this
for a class i would not have enjoyed it
because
you're trying to force comprehension
when this is it's about enjoyment it's
about
feeling the emotions and i definitely
felt that it's like a huge melodrama
told
in like like somebody is like whispering
to you
in the middle of the night just like
this is their dying breath
and the reason i picked this up in the
first place was because i
loved faulkner but then i read the
opening pages
i start reading it and i go it never
lets up there's like never a pause where
you can go
okay interesting chapter it's and this
and this and this and this and this and
this and this and look closer look
closer look closer
uncover the mystery uncover the mystery
it is an intense read like it
it seriously is intense i read it so
fast i think because
not just because the writing was so full
of momentum and so
energetic and full of life but because i
was ready to get
out i needed to get out of this
headspace because it is
it was a twisted obsessive nightmarish
headspace
it's like um the ocean it's like waves
splashing against you like you can't
really fight the ocean
you just have to roll with it so that
this book deals with
implications of incest it deals with
extreme racism
you know serious warning there is heavy
use of the n-word
in this book probably more so than any
faulkner book a dark
twisted nightmare i mean they don't call
it
southern gothic for no reason am i right
all i can do during this review is say
that it has
my absolute highest recommendation give
it a shot like like don't read it if
it's
if it's not like your your cup of tea if
you read the first page and you're like
this is annoying
just don't don't read it because that's
the rest that's the whole book yeah
thanks for watching like and subscribe
if you are
in into that sort of thing and um thanks
for watching